Hello, hello!
Maria, welcome to the world premiere this evening.
How do you feel to be on the red carpet?
Oh, I'm so happy to be here.
I'm so honored and pleased to be part of this magical universe.
You look fantastic.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Lots of fans all over the world.
So beautiful.
Yes.
Well, it's definitely true that the wizarding world fan base is a global thing.
I'm curious to know how did the fans...
How are the fans reacting back in Brazil, to you being part of the wizarding world?
Yeah, there are lots of fans in Brazil.
Yeah, it's huge!
Yeah, it's amazing.
I'm so happy, yeah.
Do you have any fond memories that you remember being on set?
Specifically, I know it's been awhile,...
...coming here to celebrate it, but does anything stand out to you...
...that was some of the best parts of being in the wizarding world?
There are some, but I remember the day they gave me the wand.
It was kind of special, you know.
Yeah, yeah!
Yes, I didn't know it was something like that.
Yeah.
It's a bit beautiful.
It's a big moment for any wizard or witch, also for any actor...
...to be in the room where they get to do that.
I didn't expect to feel like that.
Yes!
You know, it was special; it was beautiful.
Yes, I understand, I understand.
Well, thank you, thank you for your time.
Enjoy tonight and I look forward to seeing you later.
Thank you.
My pleasure!